SIRUI SUN: Good
afternoon, everyone
and welcome to Best Practices
for GCE Enterprise Deployments.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
I know we're in the
homestretch of Next.
So, I really appreciate
that you all could be here.
My name is Sirui.
I am a product manager on
the Compute Engine team,
and the goal for
the next 15 minutes
is going to be for me to share
with you all some of the best
practices and learnings that
we've picked up over the years,
and working both internally at
Google and with our customers
to deploy truly large
deployments of GC.
And so we can have
two data sources,
as part of sharing that
information with you today,
we have two data sources.
The first one is the
learnings that we picked up
that I just talked about.
And the second one
is going to be,
I want to share with you some
of the really exciting feature
announcements that
we've made here at Next,
as well as leading up to
Next so you have the latest
and greatest product details
to take with you as you go
and scale out your
GC Deployments.
So, the first thing
I want to talk about
is, when we talk about an
effective G Suite Enterprise
Deployment what
is our North Star?
Like, what is the goal
that we're going towards?
And so, one part of the
goal is for sure agility.
Almost every customer I talk to,
they want to get to the Cloud
to move quickly.
They want to use the scale
and the power of the Cloud
to quickly reach
their business goals
and to compete in the
space that they're in.
But the problem here is,
agility can't be our only focus,
because if you're
just moving fast,
you might be heading
straight towards a cliff
and not know it.
And so the North Star I
want to introduce here
for this talk, the goal that
we want to reach towards,
is agility with the
right guardrails.
So for example, you want to
know that you're moving quickly,
but you're doing so in
a cost-effective way
and also in a way that
satisfies your legal
and regulatory and
compliance requirements.
You're going to want to
mix the both of those,
and this talk is going to
be about how you move fast.
But it's also going to be about
how you use the tools that we
offer you in GCE, and
more broadly in GCP,
to achieve the right
guardrails as well.
So the first thing I'll do is
I'll look inside our tool box
and talk a little
bit about the tools
that you have available in GCE
to do these sorts of things,
with kind of a focus
on the new features
that we launched here at Next.
This is a 300-level talk.
I'm going to assume
some prior knowledge.
So we're going to focus
on some of the newer
and exciting things.
The first section is going to
be about choosing the right VM
types.
This is going to be
key in making sure
that your workloads run
quickly and effectively
on GCE, and also in
a cost efficient way.
So the first thing I'm
going to talk about
is the different machine
types that we offer
and there have been some
exciting new announcements
in this space
Ever since GCE
has been launched,
we've had the general
purpose machine type.
This is the machine type that
you use kind of by default,
and we find that it has the
best price-performance ratios
in general and
that is well suited
for a lot of
different workloads.
You should always start here
when assessing your workloads,
and we've seen them
effectively used
for all sorts of
different workloads,
including web serving,
databases, mobile gaming,
you name it.
So, you start here, but we
had this for a long time,
and we heard a lot
of customers say,
well, I have maybe a very
large in-memory database that
needs to store a ton
of data in that VM
for, say online
analytical processing.
And so at a previous
Next, we announced
the memory-optimized
machine types.
These, upon the
initial announcement,
these [? new ?] VM supported
up to 4 terabytes of memory.
But in the time
since then, we've
heard from a lot of customers
that, well, my database
is constantly growing as the
data that I work with expands,
and so we want to make sure that
we have the VM shapes to keep
up with that.
Here at this event,
we announced that we
will have memory-optimized
machines will extending
that line to have up to
12 terabytes of memory,
and that's coming soon.
Another type of workload that
we hear from customers a lot
about, is they
have workloads that
are very compute-performance
intensive.
And so in response
to that, we're
announcing here the
compute-optimized line
in machine shapes.
So why would you want this
particular type of machines?
We have customers
that are really
sensitive to
real-time performance.
So for example, if you're
running a AAA gaming server,
every millisecond
counts and you want
to make sure you have the
fastest per core performance.
Another reason you'd want this
is, we see some customers,
they have licensing agreements
where they license per core.
And so they want to
squeeze the most juice out
of each core as possible.
So those are two reasons to
look into the compute-optimize
machine type.
This is now in alpha.
So if one of those
cases sounds like it'd
be useful for your
workloads, I encourage
you to check out the blog
post that we have on this
and you'll have a sign
up link for the alpha.
That's all I'll go into
for machine shapes,
but I just want to
call out that there
was a session two days
ago that goes much more
deeply into detail, and
all of these sessions we
posted on YouTube.
So check this out if
it's interesting to you.
Another tool that we
offer here at Google Cloud
is the idea of
custom machine types.
The general purpose
line of VMs that I just
talked about, they do come
with some cookie-cutter
configurations.
But at the same
time, you actually
have the flexibility to change
the shape of the machine
in increments of two
vCPUs, or increments
of one gigabyte in memory.
And we find that,
especially as customers
start to round the
corner of Cloud adoption
and become more mature
in their deployments,
that they can get a lot
of bang for their buck
by right-sizing their machines
using custom machine types.
So for example, if you
start with a cookie-cutter
configuration but
then you realize
that you're underutilizing
your memory,
you can just scale back the
memory for that instance.
You shut down the instance,
scale back the memory,
and then turn it back
on again, and you'll
see that the memory
has gone down.
It's really easy to do this.
If you go into the UI, you'll
just see a set of sliders here,
or G Cloud, you can use the
custom CPU, a custom memory
flag.
Another use case we hear
from customers a lot,
is they might have
fault-tolerant jobs,
or short-lived tasks
that they need to do.
Maybe they don't really care
when these tasks happen,
and maybe these tasks are kind
of embarrassingly parallel.
It's a little bit of computation
that you can spin up, finish,
and then go on.
Examples of this include
rendering or genomics, or media
trance coding, and
for those use cases,
we have the preemptible
machine VMs.
So preemtible VMs,
they're offered
in the same machine types and
machines shapes that I just
talked about.
They'll last for up
to 24 hours, but they
can be preempted within that
24-hour time period with a 30
second notification.
The tradeoff being
that they're up to 80%
cheaper than regular instances.
And so we hear a
lot of customers,
when they start
their Cloud journey,
they'll make everything a
regular or non-preemtible VM.
But as they deploy, they start
to identify certain workloads
that fit this
criteria, and then they
can migrate those jobs to
be pre-emptive instead.
And in doing so,
save a lot of money.
You can think of it
as a setting on a VM
when you create it
and you can just
set the preemptible flag there,
and you're off to the races
with a preemptible VM.
As we've kind of matured
with our customers,
another thing we
started to hear is
that some customers are
really sensitive to what
they call single-host tendency.
So they say, I'm happy
moving to the Cloud,
but the host machines
that host my VMs,
I don't want them hosting
VMs from other customers.
Now, this might be because they
have regulatory or compliance
requirements that evolved
in an on-premises world,
which meant that that's
how they've always--
this is how they've
always operated,
and they don't want to go
and change those compliance
requirements, or
this might be because
of licensing limitations.
For those use cases,
we've recently GA'd what
we call sole-tenant nodes.
So this is the ability to
take a physical server,
and reserve it just for your
use cases and just for your VMs.
So what does it look like?
On the left here, we
see a normal host.
This is a non-sole-tenant node.
This is what you've
always been using on GCE.
We manage the host
hardware in both cases,
but in this particular
case, other customers
may have VMs that are also
running in the same host
hardware.
We, of course, manage
the isolation for you,
and all that.
But if you have certain
requirements that I just
talked about, you can move
on to a sole-tenant host.
There, what's
happening is, you now
have this machine reserved
exclusively for your VMs.
But you should
note, that you still
have the flexibility
within that machine
to set up VMs of
different shapes and sizes
and to change the configurations
of sizes as needed.
This is a bit of
a newer feature.
We're just starting to
see some adoption there.
But I want to walk through
what that looks like so you
can get a sense of how
easy this is to actually go
ahead and deploy it.
So we're inside the
developer console of the UI.
All of these features that
I'm going to talk about
are accessible from the UI,
and the G Cloud, and the API
surface, but I think the UI
just makes it a little clearer
sometimes to walk through.
Here we are in the UI.
We're in the Compute
Engine section,
we click on sole-tenant nodes.
You can see I'm asked
to just create one.
In creating one, I'm just
asked for a few configuration
settings, like what do
you want to call it,
and how big do you
want the machine to be.
It's just a few-step process.
And once I've created it,
you'll see an entry here.
Kind of hard to see, but
basically, that line entry
there represents a
single sole-tenant host,
ready to host your VMs.
Here you can see this
particular configuration--
or maybe you can't
see it, but it
has 96 vCPUs, and over
600 gigabytes of RAM
and you can fit as
many VMs in there
as you want that fit
within that configuration.
From there, when
you create a VM,
you can just specify the
sole-tenant node group
that you want the
VM to fit into,
and everything else is the same.
Every other part of managing
that VM is the same as before,
same as you're used to,
as long as you specify
that particular node group,
which you can see in the G
Cloud command over there.
You'll find that the
VM is now going to be
hosted in dedicated hardware.
One thing that we think
this will really help on,
is it'll allow you to bring
your existing licenses to GCP.
As we've been working with
enterprise-grade customers,
we found that many of them have,
for example, Microsoft software
licenses, already-purchased;
Microsoft Windows
licenses, already purchased.
And that the cost for
them on GCE, up until now,
sometimes the cost
for the licensing
was actually overshadowing
the costs of the vCPU and RAM
for these customers.
One of our biggest
goals in the past year
was to allow you to take these
licenses that you had already
purchased from Microsoft or
from other software vendors,
and apply them to GCP so that
you don't have to rebuy them
when you're on GCP.
At Next, we
announced the ability
to bring your own license.
This is in BETA.
And the way this works is, you
can set up a sole-tenant node,
and in doing so, you'll be
compliant with the Microsoft
bring your own
license requirements
for dedicated hardware
and per core licensing.
And in doing so,
you can then apply
the licenses you've
already purchased
to your GCE deployment.
So you have some options here.
I want to walk
through some of them.
So this option actually
already existed
even before we did this work,
but in talking with customers,
we found that very
few customers actually
realized this was
an option, so I just
want to reiterate it here.
So, in this option you
don't use sole-tenant nodes,
you just use our typical
multi-tenant hardware.
And it turns out, if you
have software assurance
with Microsoft, you can use
the license mobility program
to bring software
licenses into GCP already.
For example, for SQL Server.
In this configuration,
you're still
paying for the premium
Windows images in GCP,
but you can at least bring
your software licenses
to your GCP hardware.
Option two, this is the
one we're announcing here,
is you would use the
sole-tenant nodes that we just
talked about.
Those sole-tenant nodes are
compliant with the Microsoft
bring your own license
requirements, such
that they allow you to bring
both your Windows licenses
and your Microsoft
software licenses onto GCP,
and you don't need to
have software assurance
from Microsoft in
order to do so.
We're already seeing
some customers move
on to this particular
model, and it really
allows them to get the mileage
from their existing software
licenses, and apply that
to apply that to GCP.
OK, so the next section
I want to talk about
is around managing your data.
So before, we were talking
about virtual machines.
Now I want to talk about
the disks and the images
and the snapshots that you
have in Compute Engine,
and the tools that we
offer you to manage them
and to give you some
guardrails behind them.
The first thing--
and this is something
we've been hearing
increasingly from customers,
especially those in
regulated industries,
is they might have
some compliance
or regulatory
requirements around,
I need to control how
my data is encrypted
and how my data is
managed in Compute Engine.
I need to make sure that,
for example, if I had to,
I can totally revoke
access for that data
from everybody, including
the Cloud provider, including
Google.
A practice that's increasingly
being adopted we're seeing
is the use of--
so what happens is the customers
can create keys and Cloud
key management service.
That's a managed service that
we offer for key management
and key storage.
And what you can do is
you go ahead and create
a key in Cloud KMS,
you point GCE to it,
and then GCE will
automatically start
encrypting your disks and images
and snapshots with those keys.
And at any moment,
you can actually
revoke access of those keys from
GCE, and what that means is GCE
will stop having
access to the data.
So let's walk through that a
little bit, just a bit more
concrete detail.
You would first start by
creating a key ring and a key
in Cloud KMS.
That's a very quick process.
You would specify, for
example, the rotation
period and the name of the
key and where it lives.
And then from there,
when in GCE, you
go to actually create a
disk or image or snapshot,
you'll find an option
to point GCE to the key
that you just created.
Here in the UI, you can see
it's one of the few options.
You have G Cloud as well.
You have the KMS
key flag, where you
can specify the URI for the
key, and that's and that's
basically it.
Once you've done
that, you've told
GCE to protect your disks
and images and snapshots
with that particular key.
And from there, you can
revoke access as needed.
You can do that in the
UI by just clicking
on the disable option
there, or there's
a disabled command and G Cloud.
And from there, you'll find a
Compute Engine now no longer
has access to that data.
For example, if you took that
disk and you tried mounting it
to a VM, or if the disk is was
already mounted onto the VM
and you started
it, you would find
that those actions would fail
until the key was restored.
Another thing we've
heard from customers,
especially those
in other regions,
is they want the ability
to store all data
in a particular location.
So for example, we have a
lot of customers in Europe,
and what they tell us
is, I need to make sure
that none of my data
lives in anywhere else
other than the European Union.
Up until this point,
persistent disks
have always been regional
or zonal resources.
That meant you have
control over exactly
where those disks lived.
Up until this point, though,
images and snapshots--
so images are used
to create disks,
and snapshots are used
to backup disk state--
they have been global resources.
And so that's been convenient
for say, a global software
deployment, where you can
have a global deployment
and a single image
resource that's global
and it's supporting
that entire deployment,
or backups that support
a global deployment.
But customers have
been asking us
for a lot more flexibility
in being able to say,
I want this particular
image or snapshot
to live in a particular
region or location,
and only live in that location.
We're announcing
here the ability
to specify storage locations
for both images and snapshots.
Now, for snapshots, it
turns out that's already
been released to BETA.
We did that in the
lead up to Next.
But we're also going to for
sure be doing that for images
as well.
That's coming soon to alpha.
The way this works
is it's very simple.
There should be a
minimal influence
to any of your workflows.
But if you go into--
so, we're back in the
Compute Engine UI.
This is the list of snapshots.
We'll do this for the
list of images as well.
It will just tell
you for each snapshot
now, where that actual storage
location of the data is.
And similarly, when you're
creating that image,
or when you're
creating that snapshot,
you'll have an
option now to say,
this is where I want that
image or snapshot to live.
If you don't
specify that option,
it'll continue to be
multi-regional the way
it always was.
You can see the associated
G Cloud command there.
It's fairly easy, but
much more flexibility.
Another thing we
saw customers do
is they're using snapshots
to make sure they have
backups of the state of VMs.
And what we saw a
lot, was a pattern
of customers writing
their own automation,
writing their own
tooling to make sure
that these snapshots were
generated on a regular basis.
Say every day, or every
week, or every month.
And we saw so much of this and
so much of these custom tools,
that we thought, hey, you
know what, we should actually
offer an easy way for you to
do this that's Google managed
and that reduces the maintenance
overhead on your side.
Leading up to
Next, we introduced
what we call scheduled
snapshots to BETA.
So this is a publicly
available feature now.
We highly encourage
you to go play with it.
And what this will
do is it allows
you to tell us, the platform,
to automatically take snapshots
for you on a regular basis.
Here's what that
looks like, so now
if you go into the
snapshots view,
you'll see a new tab here
called snapshots schedules.
This is where you can
create and modify schedules.
If I were to go and
create a schedule,
I could specify a
bunch of things.
For example, when do I want
this schedule to execute,
how long do I want these
snapshots to stick around for,
what should I do if the disk is
deleted, things of that sort.
So here, in particular, I'm
creating a snapshot schedule
that's set to run daily and to
take snapshots at around noon.
Once I have that schedule, I
can then click into a disk,
so here I am in
the lists of disks.
I can click into that, and then
apply the snapshot schedule
to the disk.
So here I am inside the
edit disk page here,
and I apply the snapshot
schedule that I just created.
Easy as that.
And from here, you'll
see that Compute Engine
is going to automatically start
applying that schedule for you.
These snapshot schedules,
they don't charge.
There's no charge associated
to creating these schedules.
You're just going to be
paying for the storage
of the snapshots
as you always have.
And the other nice
thing about this
is snapshots are
differential in nature, which
means when you take
a snapshot, it's only
storing the differential
between the current time
and the previous snapshot.
What that means is
if your disk is not
changing very much in
between the snapshots,
you won't be charged very
much and in particular,
if the disk doesn't
change at all,
you won't be charged at all.
So another powerful tool--
we just rolled this out.
We're already seeing
some great adoption
from some of our early
adopters, and they've
said that it's been able to
allow them to basically throw
away all of the custom
tooling and scripts
that they've built around this.
OK, so that was a recap of
some of the new features
and a few of the best
practices around GCE,
but a common question
we get asked,
kind of around this
point as we start
to talk about best practices
is, how do I make sure
that the people in
my organization,
that developers my
organization, are actually
following these best practices?
How do I monitor what's
going on in my organization?
And then, how do
I start to enforce
some certain set of best
practices or policies,
and start to put
up those guardrails
so that I can make
sure that people
are doing the right thing?
And to motivate this, I want to
talk about sprawl for a second.
So this here is a
picture of urban sprawl.
This is San Francisco
looking out over the horizon.
And you can see there's
buildings, buildings,
and buildings everywhere.
Similarly, when
we've been working
with some of our enterprise
customers, what we see
is the concept of Cloud sprawl.
So you open up GCP
to your developers,
and almost overnight,
what we've seen
is you have hundreds or
thousands of projects spring
up, because every developer
gets their hands on it.
They do some code
labs or tutorials,
every time they do that,
a new project spins up.
All of a sudden you have
thousands of projects.
And in that
environment, it can be
very difficult to wrap
your head around what there
is in your
organization, and also
to make sure that people are
following the best practices.
It can just devolve
into a bit of a mess.
And so that's what this
section is all about,
is how do you make
sense of that mess.
How do you start to
govern that mess.
Part of the mess is good,
because it's agility
and it's people moving
quickly, but you
want to make sure that, again
they're not falling off a cliff
and doing so.
The first thing I want to
talk about a little bit
is the resource hierarchy.
What we found working
with customers
is that building a
proper resource hierarchy
is a really, really great
force multiplier for you
to help you understand
what all is going on
in your organization.
This is a 300 level
talk, so I'm not
going to dwell too much on
this particular diagram,
although I hope
you've seen it before.
But in general, I just want to
reiterate that in Google Cloud,
you have resources like the
VMs and disks in subnets.
Those roll up into projects.
So every resource
must have a project.
And then projects roll up
optionally into folders,
and then folders roll
up into organizations.
And what happens
here is, when you
set a policy on a
particular say, folder,
it'll roll down into the
projects, and then from there,
it'll roll down into resources.
And what that lets
you do is, it lets
you start grouping
resources that you
want to have similar policies
on together so that you
don't have to reason over
those resources individually.
And once you have that
resource hierarchy,
it allows you to just have a
lot more human comprehensibility
around your decisions.
So that was super abstract.
Recently I was
talking to a customer,
and this is one of
our biggest customers,
and the person
said, well, we heard
that spiel like, 100
times, even still,
after two years of
deploying Google Cloud,
we still don't really
have a resource hierarchy.
We just have thousands of
projects all reporting up
into a single organization.
And when I asked the
individual why, they said,
well, we know what a folder
is, we knew what a project is,
we never really just had
an understanding of how
to put it all together,
or any case studies
or anything like that.
So I'm glad to report that that
particular individual has now
actually--
that organization has gone
on and built a very effective
resource hierarchy.
But in case any of you
are in that same boat,
I wanted to share a much
more concrete example.
And this is how
Google internally
has structured our
resource hierarchy.
So it turns out we have over
4 and 1/2 million projects
reporting up into
Google.com, and you
can imagine in that
situation how much of a mess
it might be if you had to reason
over all of those projects
individually.
And so we've done some things
with our folder hierarchy
to try to make sense of that.
So the first thing we
have is the concept
of what we call the
Google default folder.
This is a folder
that encapsulates
all of the sandbox projects that
our developers end up creating.
And what that means
is we can start
reasoning over those
sandbox projects
together, rather
than one by one.
So we limit our
end users to only
be able to create
projects willy-nilly
in this particular folder.
That means we know this folder
has all the sandbox projects,
and in turn, we can then apply
the policies that make sense
on these sandbox projects.
For example, we can
apply a policy that says,
well you know what, sandbox
projects probably shouldn't
have external IP addresses.
They probably
shouldn't be accessible
from the public internet.
Or something like,
sandbox projects,
they probably shouldn't
have VMs that are too large
or that are running overnight,
or off business hours,
because maybe there's not
a much use case for that.
So continuing along
those lines, we
have another set
of like policies,
which is for demo projects.
So in this particular case,
we have a bunch of demos,
maybe they're being
built by the sales team
with the developer
relations team.
We grouped them into a folder.
Some policies will
apply for all demos.
For example, it's
probably OK for a demo
to have an external IP
address in some cases.
It's probably OK for
you to share demos
with external audiences
in some cases.
What we found is that there are
also some differences between
how different teams want
to handle the demos,
and so we split into
some sub-folders below--
one for the sales team, and
one for the developer relations
team--
so that we can delegate
some additional access
to those teams, and say, you
get to manage your policies
within this folder.
Another thing we noticed is that
the dev and test environments
for our different
engineering teams
all tend to sort
of look the same.
And so we have a teams folder.
There we apply some
general policies
for what dev and tests
should look like,
but then we also have
individual team folders
that our individual
teams can manage,
and then we delegate access to.
Another thing that
we found at Google
is that we do have
some subsidiaries,
some acquisitions.
We do want to group
them under the top level
org, because we want
to keep tabs on them,
and because we want to
still be able to reason over
all of the resources
in our organization.
But then we break them off
into sub-folders like Verily
in Google X, and then
give broad delegation
administrative powers to
those particular subsidiaries.
And this is a
pattern that we see
happen a lot for other
companies as well
when they deal
with acquisitions.
And then finally, we have
the production folder.
The production folder we found
just like with dev and test,
production tends to have a
similar set of policies applied
to them.
So we apply those policies
to the top level production
folder, where they go down into
all of the folders, sub-folders
and sub-resources.
But then we do have individual
services as well in there.
And then we allow the individual
teams access to those folders
and we allowed them to set their
own policies there as well.
So this is a simplified
version of a resource hierarchy
that we use at Google.
It's also by far not the
only way to do it, for sure,
but I hope this gives
you an example of how
you can take 4 and
1/2 million projects
and start grouping them into
folders in a way that allows
you to reason over
them more easily,
and allow you to set policies
over them more easily.
OK, so once you have
a resource hierarchy,
another question that
comes is, how do I
more easily see all that's
going on in my organization?
This is a problem
regardless of how
well-structured your
research hierarchy is,
although the
hierarchy does help.
I want to talk about
the tools that we
offer you to help
monitor your enterprise,
to help see what's going
on inside that sprawl,
and who's creating virtual
machines, who is creating data,
and things of that sort.
So there's two tools
I want to talk about,
and we're going to build
them up into some use cases
as we go along.
The first one is audit logs.
So, audit logs are going
to give you a real time
view of the individual
events that are going on
in your organization.
There are three types, and you
can think of these three types
as combining together
to give you that view.
The first type is
admin activity.
These are going to log
the administrative actions
that users are taking,
like creation and deletion
and modification of resources.
The second type is
the system event.
These are going
to log the events
that GCE is taking on your
behalf to maintain your VMs.
So for example, instance 01
was live-migrated at 1 PM.
And the third type
is data access.
This tracks not modifications,
but just reads of resources.
So for example, Alice at
1 PM listed all the images
in her project All of these
lines are created in real time
with sub-second latencies.
And that opens up some really
interesting possibilities
as you start to ingest these
logs that we'll talk about
in a second.
There are also
immutable, so users
can't go in and
actually change the logs
after they were created.
Admin activity logs-- the system
of logs will last for over
a year--
by default, retained over
a year, and data access
logs for 30 days.
And all of these logs can
be exported to Cloud storage
BigQuery or Pub/Sub.
Once you do that,
especially when you export
to Cloud storage
or BigQuery-- now,
obviously the retention policies
don't apply to them anymore.
You can retain them
as long as you want.
And for a Pub/Sub, this opens
up the door to some actions
that you can take immediately
once autologs are generated.
Admin activity logs
and system event logs
are generated by
default. They're
on by default for all projects.
Whenever a user
creates a project,
those audit logs
will start flowing.
And finally, admin activity logs
and system event logs are not
charged at all, whereas
data access logs,
they are charged
by ingress volume.
So data access logs, in
general, the best practice here
is if you know you need it,
we suggest you turn them on.
There's even a way to
blacklist certain users,
so that they don't
generate data access logs.
But you should be cautious of
the ingress volume charges.
To make this a little
bit more concrete,
we can take a look at what an
audit log actually looks like.
We provide a number of
ways for you to go in
and actually view
your audit logs.
Here I am in the
developer console.
I can go into the
logging section here,
and I'll just see a list
of all the audit logs,
and then I can filter
down that list as needed.
And if you look into a
particular audit log,
you'll find that we provide a
really rich set of information
for each.
Here's a particular
admin activity
log for a user that
stopped the GCE instance,
and you'll see the email address
of the user, what they did,
what resource they acted on,
and if they had any other,
for example, fields
in the request body,
you would see all
of that as well.
And so, you really get
a lot of visibility
into what users are doing
in your organization.
And so a question that
tends to come up is,
OK well, I have 4,000 projects.
They're all
generating audit logs.
Do I have to go
into each project
to chase that
project down and make
sure it's exporting somewhere?
Or in other words, how can I
have all these other logs going
to a single place, so that
no matter how many projects I
have in my organization, no
matter how many folders I have,
I can make sure
that I still have
visibility over all of that.
And so a best
practice here is, we
have a feature called
aggregated logs export
that lets you do that.
With aggregated
logs export, you can
specify at an organization
or a folder level
that all of the projects beneath
that organization or folder
are sending your audit logs
to a single centralized place.
So here's the G Cloud
command to do that.
So what we're saying is, G
Cloud logging syncs creates.
So we're creating a new export.
We're exporting to
a particular bucket,
which is above this line.
This line says,
we want to export
for this particular
organization.
We're saying we
want to filter down
to just the admin activity logs.
Maybe that's what
we're interested
in this particular example.
And then we're saying, this is
the most important flag here,
the include children
flag says, apply this
to not only this
organization, but actually
to all of the
projects and folders
and resources underneath
that organization.
With this one line,
we're able to answer
that previous
question, and we're
able to make sure that we have
a single GCS bucket with all
of the events that are happening
in my entire organization
and this is getting
updated in real time.
A real world example
of what we've
seen folks do with
audit logs is, well,
here's a real world example.
We have companies that are
really interested in reacting
to insider risks.
And sometimes they might
have an insider risks warning
around a user who may have had
their credentials compromised,
who may be doing some unwanted
things inside the organization.
With audit logs, and with
the search functionality
in audit logs, you can use that
to easily filter down the audit
logs to just the actions
that a particular user took.
So in this particular
example, what we're doing is--
for this G Cloud
command for example,
we can say I want to
read the audit logs
that just go against GCE
instances, that are just
about admin activity,
and that just
involve this particular Alice
user that I'm interested in.
You can also zoom
in, for example,
on a particular instance to see
the history of that instance.
Now, in this particular
example, we're
just looking at a
particular project.
But you can imagine how you
can combine this particular use
case with the previous one where
you're aggregating all the logs
across your organization
to easily search
against all the activities
that are happening
in your organization.
And we find that to be
a really powerful tool.
Now, we released audit
logs a long time ago,
and we've seen a
lot of adoption,
but sometimes we
get the question of,
I don't care so
much about the view
of all the events
in the world, as I
care about the state
of all of my resources
at a given point in time.
And this is sort of possible to
reconstruct using audit logs,
but it takes a
little bit of work,
and it's just not an easy
streamlined thing to do.
And as a result,
we've introduced
and we've GA'd very recently
the Cloud asset inventory API.
So this is a powerful
API that will,
for any given state in time
in the past five weeks,
allow you to export what all
of your resources look like
and what all the policies on
those resources look like.
And so what does that look like?
So these are APIs.
So we'll be making
an API request
appear in the first line.
You can see we're
requesting the access token.
That's just the canonical
way to get the access token,
and then we attach it
onto the request here.
And then what we
can do is, we're
calling the Cloud
asset inventory
APIs on a particular project.
And we're saying export x
assets for that project.
You can also call them on a
folder or on an organization,
and it'll do the same thing.
In this particular
case, we're asking
for a resource as opposed to
resources and the policies.
So we're saying, get all the
resources for this project,
and then we're saying dump
that all into a GCS bucket.
So once you've done
that, you'll see
just a list of all of the
resources in that project.
Now we didn't say
what time to do it,
so the Cloud asset inventory is
assumed to do it for right now,
but you can also specify at time
anytime in the past five weeks.
This is what the
response looks like.
So in blue, you'll see some
metadata about this entry.
So this is basically us
saying, we found an instance.
Its parented to
this project, this
is the information about it.
And then in green,
you can see we've
printed out all the properties
of that particular resource.
So you'll see what the CPU
platform is, the disks attached
to it, basically every
property that you
would see from making a GET
request against that resource.
So this API has just been GA'd.
We've just started to work
with customers on this.
But we've already
found that customers
are using these
APIs to implement
a pretty powerful and
wide range of use cases.
So for example, you can, as
kind of the first thing to do,
you can just see how
many projects have
GCE resources inside of them.
Working with one
customer, we asked
them upfront before they did
this experiment, how many they
thought there were and
they said around 100.
It turns out they had
over 500 resources--
500 projects, excuse
me, with GCE resources.
They were really glad that
they made this request,
and it's just another
example of the sprawl that
happens inside organizations
that are rolling out the cloud.
You can also do things like,
how many VMs have external IP
addresses, or, how
is my persistent disk
versus local SSD mix
changing over time?
That's a cost optimization one.
Or, because this
API also tells you
about the policies
that are applied,
you can also say, hey
at a particular moment
in time, who had access to a
particular set of resources?
For example, if you
are investigating
a security incident or
something like that.
You can imagine with these
APIs and with just a little bit
of iteration over the
results, you can really
do some powerful scanning.
The last section we have here
is around enacting and enforcing
policies.
And so this is all
around, now that I
know the state of
the world, and now
that I have the
resource hierarchy
to reason over that in a
more human comprehensible
sort of way, how can I start
to put up some guardrails?
How can I start enforcing
that some of the best
practices that we just talked
about actually be implemented
by my organization at large?
And so when I say
the word policies,
I mean that in the
broadest sense of the term.
For a city, a policy
might be all buildings
need to have two fire escapes,
or buildings in this region
can only be under 20 stories.
For a Cloud, in the
Cloud world, a policy
might be for security purposes.
You might say, hey,
resources shouldn't
be shared outside
of the organization,
or this is a set
of people who can
do x on this set of resources.
They can also be for
compliance reasons.
We used the example
before of the organization
in the European Union.
They want to have
a policy that says,
my users shouldn't be
able to stand up resources
in the outside of the EU.
Or they can be for cost savings.
You can say something like,
hey, VMs in a sandbox project,
they should be shut down
on weekends and holidays
you should have VMs
underneath a certain size,
et cetera, et cetera.
There's a number of
other reasons too.
Now, when we talk about
enacting and enforcing policies,
I want to draw a dichotomy here.
You can enforce policies
before the fact, which
is to say you can place limits
on activities before they
happen.
I might say users are
not able to create
a disk in a particular
region, and if they try to,
they'll get an error.
Or we can enact policies
after the fact as well.
So we can maybe be a little
more permissive for users
and allow them to
take a certain action,
but once they take
an action, we're
constantly scanning
the environment
to see whether or not
the action happened,
to see what things are
happening and taking action
against violations of policies.
So at this point
you might ask, well,
why not only do things
before the fact?
Why am I even taking the risk of
allowing some actions to happen
and then reacting to it?
Well for some policies, for
like life or death policies,
or security policies,
you should certainly
enforce them before the fact.
That's for sure.
But if you're just enforcing
them before the fact,
how do you know that you're
doing that in the right way?
And so one reason to enforce
both before and after the fact
is defense in depth.
Let's say I don't want to have
any VMs in my organization
with external IP addresses
because I'm very worried
about data exploitation.
What I can do is, I certainly
won't allow my users to create
VMs with external IPs, but
then I also scan after the fact
to see what are all my VMs,
and do any have external IPs.
And so I can be doubly confident
that I truly am following
and abiding by the policy.
Another reason to enforce after
the fact is for things where
they're more of a best
practice, or I more
want to nudge my users
towards that behavior.
And in that case, you'll
find that by enforcing
after the fact, which I'll give
some examples on in a second,
you can be a lot more
expressive and do
a lot more actions as opposed
to enforcing before the fact.
But first we'll zoom in on
enforcement before the fact.
We have a number of tools to
set policies that will prevent
behavior before it happens.
Of course, one is
the IAM policy.
So this is using the built in
identity and access management
tools, you can extend
policies on resources
to say who can do what on them.
So for example, I can
apply a policy that
says, this particular
set of users,
they have this
set of permissions
on this organization,
so on and so forth.
We also have the concept of
an organizational policy,
so whereas IAM policies are
in the business of granting
permissions to
particular sets of users,
when you set up an
organization policy,
these are in the business
of placing restrictions
on resources.
So I can set up a organization
policy for example, that says,
I don't want any
external IP addresses.
We're also working
on another one
calling back to the
previous example, which
says I don't want to
have any resources stored
in a particular
location or region.
And finally, another
tool that we're
seeing becoming a lot more
prevalent among larger
organizations for
enforcement before the fact,
is the concept of having
a level of automation
sitting between the
users and the GCE.
This is an actual real-life
case study from one
of our customers.
What they do is, they don't
allow any of their end users
to create projects.
Instead, these users go
to a service now portal
that they've implemented.
They go in the
service now portal,
and they request a
project be created.
That asks them questions to
the user about what they want
the project to be used for, and
in turn, it might even kick off
some approval workflows.
But after that,
assuming that it's
approved, what this
service now does
is it calls up a Jenkins
job, which will automatically
create a project on
behalf of the user.
And when it creates
the project, it
is able to create the project
with some specific set
of defaults that are kind of
more trusted and more safe.
So for example, what they do
is they delete the default
network, because by default
we'll create a new network
with every single project.
And instead, they'll hook up
the project to a shared network
that they've created which is
more centrally administered,
and also in doing so, they can
set up some other good defaults
on the project, like the IAM
roles and things like that.
And in doing so, I think they've
come to a good mix of agility
with the right guardrails.
So their developers can still
move quickly, they can still
create projects as
needed, but now they
have the right guardrails
on that project
to make sure developers
don't veer off a cliff.
So this is all I'll say
on the subject for now,
but I do want to [? call ?] we
did have a session that goes
much, much deeper into
all of these topics
yesterday called Best Practices
for privacy and security
and Compute Engine.
If this subject
matter interests you,
I would highly suggest
you check that out.
You can also do
enforcement after the fact.
And this is where some of
the really interesting pieces
come together.
So one best practice
we're seeing in the field
is the ability to take automated
actions from audit logs.
So as I mentioned before, you
can actually export an audit
log to Pub/Sub,
and what that means
is as those actions
happen in real time,
you'll get a push to Pub/Sub
that you can then subscribe to,
and then you can
take actions on.
So at the start of
the talk, I talked
about schedule snapshots
and the ability
to set up those schedules.
Let's say you wanted to
enforce that as a best
practice in your organization.
You want to say, anytime
a disk is created,
I want to encourage
my users, or I
want to create a schedule
snapshot for those users.
So what you could
do, for example,
is you could take your logs and
export them to Cloud Pub/Sub,
and you might constrain
or filter your logs
to just the ones that are disk
creation events or VM creation
events that have disk
creation associated with them.
So now you have a
Cloud Pub/Sub topic
that has basically a constant
stream of every disk that's
being created in
your organization.
And from there, you can
set up Cloud Functions
or any other kind
of managed service,
or it could even be a VM that
just listens to this Pub/Sub
topic that you set up.
So basically, it gets triggered
every time a disk gets
created in your organization.
And what it can
do is it can read
that audit log, it can
understand whether or not
this disk has a schedule
snapshot attached to it,
and if not, it can take action.
So it might, for example,
email the creator
and say, hey, I notice
you didn't have a schedule
snapshot.
You should probably attach one.
Or it could go further and
just automatically create
a snapshot for you.
So in this case you're sharing
to guide your organization
towards a set of best
practices, and you also
see how this approach has
a lot more flexibility.
It takes a little bit more work,
but has a lot more flexibility
and kind of how
heavy handed you want
to be with your guardrails.
You can also imagine if you
have an aggregated log export,
you can make this even easier.
You can scale this across
your entire organization,
because now you can
deploy this once
and it applies to all the
logs that are being generated
across your organization.
Another best practice
we're seeing,
and this is around automated
scanning of your environments,
using the information
from the automated scan
to check for [? pilot ?]
policy violations.
So in the example
here, let's say
we want to ensure that no disks
exist outside of the European
Union.
Then what I can do is
I can use a Cloud asset
inventory to export all of
the disks in my organization
to GCS.
Once I have that list,
it's a pretty simple job
to just iterate over that file,
detect the region for each disk
And if there is a disk
outside of the European Union,
I can take the
appropriate action.
Maybe that means
I file a ticket,
or I contact the person who owns
it, or a more extreme version,
I can just go and
delete that disk.
And then you can wait some
interval and repeat step one.
So you can constantly be
scanning your environment,
and in doing so, it's
also a great vehicle
to start enforcing
some of these policies.
So with that, that brings
us to the end of this talk.
Hopefully this has been
helpful in showing you
some of the best
practices and the tools
that we have for
enterprise deployments.
Thank you very much.